earlier we spoke with nasa astronaut
christina cook about the significance of
this mission now she's a member of the
artemis team and she's also got quite
the resume listen to her numbers she
spent
328 consecutive days in space that's the
longest of any woman and she conducted
six spacewalks go christina what are
they looking for
well we're looking for a lot of
different things one of the primary
missions is to make sure that the heat
shield can withstand those reentry
conditions we'll be going a lot faster
than we typically go when we come back
from what we call low earth orbit which
is where i went on the space station so
that's a primary objective we're looking
at all the different human factors that
will become
in play when we put humans on the next
vehicle things like radiation some of
the life support things so we're doing a
lot of testing that thing is
instrumented all the way up and down and
we can't wait to get the data back and
see what's going to happen next
christina that pardon me that's the
vehicle itself what about putting feet
on the moon again why is that important
for the mission to mars
you know there's so many reasons why
going back to the moon is is happening
right now this is the right time for it
we're going back to stay this time for
innovation for inspiration and of course
for that interplanetary aspect of our
next step onto mars we're going to take
the technologies the operations lessons
that we learn and we're going to bring
that on our next step and really that's
all about searching for life learning
more about our solar system the universe
and our place in it so i can't wait to
see all that unfold in the next decade
christina you could be part of the crew
that actually steps foot on the moon
first time in 50 years that's that's
been done it'd be the south pole of the
moon why is that area significant if you
could
there's a lot of scientific reasons we
would go back to the south pole actually
one of which is water ice that was a
recent discovery there so research
resources that are there that we can use
are exciting there are craters there
that actually never see the sun because
of the sun angle and because of the the
depth of the crater so there's a lot of
really neat scientific reasons to go
back to the south pole and the
technology of this mission actually
enables us to go to those different
regions as opposed to the landing sites
of the apollo missions
and if you get to go christina we'll be
cheering you on we'll be cheering you on
thank you so much
thank you so much for joining us this
morning